okay so uh YouTube video recently that
said that there's some really seedy like
uh crazy duto
world of yachting
yacht like the dark side of yachting
being oh [__] luxury Yachts what's the
dark side of it the dark side I've been
on a yacht I thought it was pretty
[__] cool
right into the dark side yeah okay it's
the ultra rich people yeah on the yachts
and they like hire all kinds of models
to to get on the yacht and it's
understood that model's gonna put out oh
for sure that has to be so it's like
basically and and then this this this
YouTube video about the Dark Side of
yachting like suggested that
it's been alleged that like all kinds of
like high level like like uh yeah it's
international waters you know I'm like
acting as anything can happen out there
like maybe like doing some favors for
some dough like and and then even the
it's it's uh suggested that this is a
way into the entertainment industry it's
got to go on this Yachts get paid a
little bit do some favors
something strange well [__] man I'm
trying to go on this yeah
fantastic yeah
we started to think that all these
pictures we see of Leonardo Dicaprio and
Yachts that he might be getting some
action on there
I don't think I think those girls would
want to [__] Leo regardless of whether
he's on a yacht or not but uh yeah I
know though the I just went on like an
awesome trip
um my friend Nina Dobrev who I'm in the
Outlaws with it was her birthday and
they they got like a yacht in Indonesia
and I went to Indonesia and like spent
some time but there weren't any hookers
on there so it was a different vibe much
different you know it was just like uh
friends hanging out yeah yeah Indonesia
the yacht's like 12 bucks out there yeah
it was it was a little cheaper than in
the Bahamas I've looked into it I was
like I came back and I was like yeah
maybe I'm a yacht guy because it was
like the best vacation I've ever been on
versus so you're on a boat and they're
constantly like giving you little snacks
and like handing you a drink and you're
like this is my kind of vacation and
then I like was like I'm gonna I'm gonna
be a yacht guy like because I have a big
birthday coming up I turn 40 years old
this year yeah so I'm like you know what
I'm gonna like maybe I get a yacht for
my 40th birthday and then I looked up
how much Yachts cough and I'm like maybe
I'm not a yacht guy yeah yeah
maybe I'm like a nice hotel for a
weekend type of guy yeah
Scott just turned 40. it's nice dude
yeah yeah I was uh I looked into being
yacht the union that's what I get cars
or seasick as [__] oh really I can't
even deal yeah but I sailed around New
Zealand and now it was okay because you
just vomited for no no that was Alaska
but like the way they did it was the guy
picks you up and you just kind of like
hang out in little Bays all day yeah and
then you go to the next Bay and you go
to the next Bay but yeah that's kind of
how Indonesia was it was cool I had
never been there it was like the most
beautiful place I'd ever been I'm sure
New Zealand is wildly beautiful but it
was like uh there's so many islands that
it like there's no like break there's no
like waves anywhere so it was just like
a lake with Crystal Blue Water
Everywhere it was rad
Indonesia they have killer waves well
not where I was yeah but I'm sure
there's like if you go on the outside of
the islands there's like a sick breaks
but like where we were I was like this
is like the flattest that had been taken
you to a [__] and break would you have
been shrop in it uh no dude I suck at
surfing like I'm the worst uh what does
shrope mean okay okay
uh no I suck dude do you like shopping
on Amazon I do and good news is Stevo's
butt wipes for your butt hole are
available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude